what's the deal with the ball drop
[Music]
Chuck why'd you call my geek phone
what's up what's up with that well uh
it's flashing first of all and I what's
what's that I the reason I had to use
the phone is because first thing I did
was put the uh mustache in the sky oh
clearly you didn't see that people don't
know that you know like when you want
Batman you put the bat signal in the sky
when you want Neil you take a signal
light and you put a mustache I missed
that song it's a big mustache in the sky
I was drinking eggnog or something I
wasn't looking it must have been that
was a rare time I was not looking up
okay
so I had I had to ring the geek phone
instead but the real deal is uh I was
thinking about because it's New Year's
and it's a big deal
and there's a ball in Times Square where
people show up at five o'clock in the
evening
to wait seven hours peeing in a bottle
peeing in a bottle okay
so that they can watch this ball it's
robbed and I was like what what is the
deal with the ball dropping okay all
right all right so you check me because
I know stuff you're saying right now
anything I want I told you I call you
black Google okay
I don't know everything but it turns out
I totally know why they dropped the ball
because it has history with my people my
people an astrophysicists and the
astronomers of yester Century uh we all
established
this tradition it's to have no roots in
celebrating the new year it has
everything to do with the sky and
navigation
so a couple of things first let me just
put it out there that it is weird that
everyone celebrates an exact moment with
a countdown of seconds
in 24 different time zones
all an hour apart from each other right
so so people are thinking that it's some
instant well if it's really an instant
then the whole world should celebrate
that instant but it doesn't right right
they're just celebrating this time in
their time zone for me that's a little
weird I think we should all get together
and say when do you want to celebrate
this and make that the moment and that
may shift throughout the decades you
know depending on astronomical factors
but so but anyhow time keeping that's my
people
that's my how long is a day Chuck
uh 24 hours no no how how do we decide
the length of a day oh a rotation of the
Earth Earth a planet like how do we
decide the duration of a year on a trip
around the sun earth going around the
Sun that's my people okay even a month
one day at one time known as a month
that is just that that does not work for
me
you know excuse me what move is it I'm
just saying all right so oh by the way a
lot of words that were altered over the
years just to simplify them the people
who complain when you don't say Merry
Christmas you say happy holidays and
they say we're good put the religion
back in you got to put Jesus and Holiday
comes from the word holy day right two
words holy day right so it's happy holy
days that that's completely so you're
actually still you're still in the same
thing
Merry Christmas or happy holiday you're
really saying happy holy day right so
it's awesome yeah yeah it's all that so
that's just to put it out there for
those there you go you want to keep
saying happy holiday it comes from that
whether or not you knew it you're
wishing someone happy holy day right
okay yeah all right and the move
happy holy day enjoy the rest
[Music]
okay can I get back to the ball drops
okay all right all right so uh forgive
me I have to do a quick calculation here
on my
um
okay
so
uh back in the day
okay in the days of navigation where we
didn't have
uh
entirely accurate
ways to know your longitude on Earth you
can always get your latitude how far
away you are from the equator at night
you could look up and where's the North
Star and how many degrees above the
Horizon is the North Star and that comes
very close to your latitude on Earth
okay period so you can get latitude okay
not a problem all right many people in
Europe would go down to a back when they
were sailing to the new world would go
to a city a port city that had the same
latitude on Earth as where they wanted
to land in the new world and you just
stay there watching the North Star at
night making sure that you kept that
heading okay and that would ensure that
you stayed on your latitude going across
longitude is a whole other another all
right how do you know where you are
in longitude these are the orange slices
from pole to pole that go east to west
on Earth how do you know your longitude
all right well first of all somebody has
to declare what the Zero longitude is
it's easy to know what the equator is
right and call that zero because the
equator is just the midpoint between the
poles that requires no geopolitics all
right well who's going to get the
starting point of the longitude somebody
is going to declare that okay will you
start counting longitude it's a
completely geopolitically arbitrary
location on Earth okay okay and due to
geopolitics in its day especially
between England and France
um France wanted the the it's called the
prime iridium France wanted it to go
through the Paris observatory in Paris
but but England won out and Paris said
well forget you we're going to introduce
the metric system how do you like that
okay so after the French Revolution they
laid the metric system on the world okay
they came up with the metric system by
the way right okay you know what the
meter was the original definition of the
meter no it's it's 110 10 millionth
the distance between earth's equator and
the North Pole on a line that passes
through the Paris Observatory
okay okay just in case you were
wondering
it's so arbitrary and yet specific yes
it is the most specific arbitrary fact
that I've ever heard in my life okay all
right so it turns out that the the
longitude the primary reading goes
through Greenwich okay Greenwich England
there's an observatory there and they
kept very accurate records of things and
one of the things they can keep track of
is the rotation of the Earth
okay there's something called a Transit
telescope so Transit telescopes a
telescope that sits and points in the
sky and it does not move okay it does
not move left to right it just goes up
or down vertically okay so and it aligns
with due south
so Watch What Happens you just put it
there and as a star
crosses your field of view you mark you
you set a time and that repeats you set
another time okay so you they know they
know where the stars are how long Earth
takes to rotate how long it takes the
sun to make it through because we're
also moving around the Sun so they have
all the data all the data so they can
tell you what time it is what local noon
is when is when is noon when the Sun
reaches its highest point in the sky and
Crosses that What's called the prime
meridian okay
um the the the the the celestial
Meridian is where it's a line from the
South Pole to the North Pole as stars in
the Sun or the moon Crossing but that's
not that's not so important as the
following fact I'm ready to go out to
sea how do I know what my longitude is
you know how I know I look at the
difference
among other things I can check but I
look at the difference between when my
son crosses my Meridian and when the sun
crosses the Meridian back where I just
left
okay so here's a port and I'm going to
leave the port and I've set the time I
match up the time okay 12 noon 12 noon
now I go sailing and I go east doesn't
matter East or West now wherever I am I
look up oh my gosh the sun crossed my
Meridian an hour earlier
oh my gosh
so I must have traveled East
an entire hour's worth of of distance
in a 24-hour day compared to where I
once was
so you just compare what's going on with
your local sky to the sky that you lined
up when you left okay if you know what
12 noon is where you left you know how
far away you are from that spot at all
times okay okay
all right so how how precise is this so
one minute
Okay one minute of time
translates into a little more than one
mile
so if you are off by five minutes if
your clock wanders or if you're you're
off you're off by five miles to your
destination if you're off by 10 minutes
you're up by 10 a little more than 10
miles okay so so you want to be as
precise as possible
okay we understand I'm with you I'm with
you okay so it's not only did you match
your clock
but the clock has to continue to be
accurate
all right it can't be oh tell me when if
am I two minutes off you won't know if
you're two minutes off because it's
that's the only clock you have
right you are sometimes they bring two
clocks and take the average of the two
or three and take the clock in the
middle all right some [ __ ] they knew
how off it was this game's a minute a
day
so that's okay as long as you know that
this sounds like my house and then you
adjust it every day all right this is
all complicated the point is
I'm at sea and I'm not going to walk to
your Observatory visible from the coast
to to match clocks
and the observatory knows this
so they say here's what we'll do
we could just ring a bell at 12 noon but
wait a minute the Bell
the sound of the Bell takes time to get
from the hillside to where the ship is
in the harbor right that takes time
okay and you say oh come on how much
time to say so I can do the math on that
okay here we go so
if I carry the two
okay so for every second
you are off
it's a hundred feet in longitude
so all right so what we're saying is
these the sound travel time time goes uh
it goes five seconds per mile okay
that's the speed so if you're half a
mile away you're two and a half seconds
away that's still distance you don't
want to be in error as you go out to see
so instead of ringing the bell
they have another method
they have a ball
that begins dropping typically at noon
one minute to noon
and it drops
this gives you a minute to anticipate at
the bottom where it hits and you take
out your shipboard telescopes you watch
it and you got the clock person right
next to you okay the Watchman
who's looking at a clock
which is where we get the term watch
from okay
I want to go buy a watch man no you're
going to buy a watch because we got rid
of the man okay yeah I'm very rich I
have a Watchman
it's just a dude that goes everywhere I
go I'm like what time is it what time is
it okay
excuse me and then sometimes they'll be
like uh I'm like uh it's a time how much
for you
anyway go ahead sorry all right so
that's my fantasy so you're looking at
it and when you see the ball hit the
bottom that is the exact moment because
light travels basically really really
fast compared with the sound right so
that time difference is not lag no real
there's no lag there no lag importance
okay and plus we did this before we even
had measured the speed of light and
before we knew the speed of light was
infinite like we didn't really know
entirely so that sets the time for all
the ships in the harbor and they they
they and they check their sea going
watch the uh
um the time keeping device and from
there they go out to see his name is
Gerald Gerald do you take Gerald except
Gerald
Jerry of course right yeah what time is
it okay
so to in Tanda with this was the was the
race to get the most accurate sea going
chronometer because there were pendulums
they had Springs and balances and things
but with all this mechanism inside of a
watch inside of the clock the time
keeping messing if the ship is rocking
that could affect the time
okay so they would try to keep the clock
like in the center line of the ship so
that maybe it didn't it doesn't Rock up
around as much so so there you have it
if you look at old maps of the new world
they get the vertical distances correct
but left to right is completely
distorted and it's because they couldn't
get the correct longitude over very long
voyages they do the best they can
yeah so so this ball dropping ritual is
a time keeping ritual that was
introduced by observatories who kept
track of the movement of the sun
movement and stars for their own use but
also for navigation and this ball
dropping thing is so they can see the
time from a distance Times Square is
nowhere near a port okay but they took
the ritual stuck it in the middle of
Times Square the intersection of
Broadway and 7th Avenue and everyone
celebrates this final minute of the New
Year in the one minute ball drop and
it's got lights and it's got the the
it'll say 2023 and people kiss and and
and make noise and drink and and and so
there you have it that is I know it's a
long it's a long-winded account but it's
fascinating who who would have known
that that
um you know going out to sea would
become a tradition that happens
worldwide because they've dropped the
ball Now everywhere yeah well they have
some kind of person form of it yeah the
good thing about a bowl is that you can
anticipate that last minute right
because the ball is moving right of
course you can have a countdown but
that's not as fun as watching well yeah
yeah watching it descend as it goes yeah
without a doubt right and it's and as
you know it's a completely unnecessary
ritual because we have GPS timings
from me I have Gerald
okay for the rest of us
[Laughter]
Chuck there it is just in time for New
Year's all right that's very cool I mean
I have to say this is something this is
why I like these I'm gonna be honest
because this is something I would have
never thought about ever well that's the
whole point of an explainer video except
the entire point I would never have
thought about this forever but now when
I'm watching a ball drop I'm going to
annoy the hell out of a lot of people
because they are getting this door
actually the ball is dropping for shut
the hell up while I drink my yard I
don't think you know but
thank you